so uh he prefers right now to use fear
to all of his
people in his team and it can make
problems for him because
they will be afraid and that means they
will be less loyal to him so maybe they
will think about what can they do to
save their lives and to protect them and
maybe to
overthrow Putin but it's these are also
fantasies for Ukraine a bit because even
with pregosium was the only one who was
capable of doing that because he had an
army behind him he had Wagner
mercenaries and the weapons about two
months ago he lost his chance and maybe
if he walked up to the Kremlin he would
be heading Russia right now but he
didn't do that and he paid with his life
for that